[Music]
incredible heat wave on the east coast
you've been reading about this it's
miserable on the east coast right now
yeah yeah uh they are so desperate for
air conditioning the that someone was
actually spotted going into a theater to
see rock of ages
he lasted 30 seconds
you came running out
it's all horrible
that's not what people were telling the
presidential campaign of course this
week a lot of people were saying that
the key to the presidential race is the
hispanic vote that's been the big story
this week yes go ahead cheer it up
yeah mitt romney has accused president
obama of pandering to the latino
community
he just said that yeah the white house
said the president is unable to comment
because he's busy watching telemundo and
eating chalupas
[Applause]
i love telemundo yeah
of course mitt romney also working hard
to win the latino vote today true story
mitt romney tried to win over a
skeptical hispanic audience in florida
yeah unfortunately romney set the wrong
tone when he came out and tossed the
crowd his car keys
just take that out back
[Music]
let's take it around and i'll i'll just
pick that up later huh
he didn't know what he had done wrong
it's interesting it's being reported
that uh stories on the internet about
mitt romney do not get a lot of web
traffic
if it's on the internet and it involves
mitt romney people really don't seem to
care yeah so today romney solved the
problem by legally changing his name to
milf romney
wow i
it's true i
i go to them eight times today by
accident
big supreme court decision yeah the
supreme court this is huge has decided
not
not to find broadcast networks for
fleeting expletives or momentary nudity
yeah
yeah not gonna do it
yeah
yeah so it looks like wheel of fortune
is about to get a lot more interesting
[Applause]
this is true though this changes our
business a lot yeah today today the
supreme court ruled that tv networks can
show
momentary nudity
yeah so by popular demand the view is
now a radio show
[Applause]
[Music]
my rocking chair listen behind you
with the whole family yeah gather round
gang yeah
gather around 1920s family the views on
the radio
there's a new uh dating website out
there have you heard about this that
helps match up people who look like each
other
like that's something you want right but
it's true there's a website that will
match you up with someone who looks like
you uh that explains why tonight i have
a very hot date with this police officer
from chagrin falls ohio
anytime a parent would express a concern
their children might be in danger and
it's considered a credible threat
there we go
[Applause]
uncanny yeah
untanny lady cop way to go
right thanks andy handcuffs you know
yeah
this is a weird story this just came out
today it's being reported that kim
kardashian's mother
was the one who ordered her to make the
sex tape that made her famous
her mom yeah she said if kim didn't do
it she was gonna get a spanking and if
she did do it she was gonna get us
banking
that was stupid uh
as opposed to the others
this is a weird one the octomom has been
hired as a spokesperson for a service
that lends money
that's true for a company lends money
yeah they chose the optomon because
their slogan is there's no hole too deep
to climb out
[Music]
you